it's really important to use analytics
with monetization because you really
want to understand your users so as an
app developer knowing more information
about users will allow you to tailor and
change things and tweak things so that
you can try to figure out okay why did
someone stop at this level maybe it was
too hard for them or maybe you have to
offer an in-app purchase or something
like that that allows them to really
understand how to get to the next piece
of monetization right so the more data
that you have the more it helps you
understand okay what do I have to do to
tweak my app to get to the next phase of
your business